Die Hallo Deutschschule
präsentiert
Kochen mit Juli und Marco
Das Rezept des Tages
Älplermagronen
Made in Switzerland
Hallo Marco.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Wie geht es dir heute?
Hallo Juli.
Mit geht es super.
Ich freue mich sehr, mit dir
heute etwas Leckeres zu kochen.
Jetzt erzähl schon.
Was hast du für uns vorbereitet?
Heute schauen wir uns ein typisch
schweizerisches Gericht an.
Das klingt super.
Lass mich raten.
Schokoladenfondue?
Das wäre natürlich auch sehr lecker.
Heute zeige ich dir,wie man Älplermagronen zubereitet.
Davon habe ich auch schon gehört.
Schmeckt das gut?
Das schmeckt sogar sehr gut
Woher kommt das eigentlich genau?
Es ist ein Gericht aus dem
schweizerischen Alpengebiet.
Es ist vegetarisch und besteht aus Teigwaren,
Kartoffeln, Käse, Rahm, Zwiebeln und Knoblauch.
Was für ein lustiger Name für ein Gericht.
Woher stammt der Name dafür?
Der Name setzt sich zusammen aus Älplerals Bezeichung für Sennen auf den Alpen.
Und Magronen, was vom italienischen
Wort „maccheroni“ übernommen wurde.
Ein ähnliches Gericht ist übrigens das in
Nordamerika und Grossbritanien beliebte “Macaroniand cheese”.
Das ist sehr interessant Juli.
Jetzt habe ich aber Hunger bekommen.
Legen wir los?
Ja, lass uns mit dem Kochen beginnen.
Zutaten für Schritt 1
2 Zwiebeln
2 Knoblauchzehen
400 Gramm fest kochende Kartoffeln
Die Zwiebeln, Knoblauchzehen unddie Kartoffeln kannst du zuerst schälen.
Danach schneiden wir die Zwiebeln in Ringe.
Den Knoblauch kannst du in Scheiben schneiden.
Und die Kartoffeln schneidest du in Würfel.
Aber pass auf, dass du dich nicht schneidest.
Nur keine Angst.
Und was macht du?
Ich passe auf, dass du alles richtig machst Marco.
Sehr lustig Juli.
Und was machen wir als nächstes?
Die Zwiebeln und den Knoblauch braten
wir in einer Pfanne goldbraun an.
Dann nehmen wir sie heraus
und stellen sie beiseite.
Bereit für Schritt 2 Marco?
Bereit für Schritt 2 Juli.
Zutaten für Schritt 2
5 Deziliter Gemüsebouillon
2 Deziliter Halbrahm
250 Gramm Teigwaren (2 Sekunden
Pause) Zum Beispiel Penne
Die Gemüsebouillon und den Rahm
kochen wir in einer Pfanne auf.
Danach geben wir die Kartoffeln
und die Teigwaren dazu.
Bei kleiner Hitze lassen wir alles ca. 10
Minuten kochen, bis die Teigwaren al dente sind.
Hast du alles im Griff Marco?
Traust du mir nicht etwa nicht?
Natürlich vertraue ich dir.
Ich leite die Frage einfach gleich weiter.
Hast du alles im Griff da unten?
Vertrauen ist gut. Kontrolle ist besser.
Zutaten für Schritt 3
Ein halber Teelöffel Salz
Wenig Pfeffer
60 Gramm geriebener Gruyère
Zum Schluss mischen wir den Käse unter
die Teigwaren und die Kartoffeln.
Noch ein wenig würzen und
dann auf dem Teller verteilen.
Das war ja einfach.
Aber ob das für uns beide reicht?
Das war‘s. Ein ganz einfaches,
aber leckeres Gericht.
Einen guten Appetit!
Haben dir die Älplermagronen geschmeckt?
Welche Gerichte kochst du gerne?
Schreibe es uns in die Kommentare.
Vergiss nicht das Video zu liken.
Kommentiere und abonniere unseren Kanal.